Let me tell you something that'll put
down your phone right now. You have
700,000 hours in your entire life.
You've probably already burned through
200,000.
And here's what's terrifying. You'll
spend 11 years just looking at screens.
11 years. Sleep takes a third. Work
takes another chunk. You're left with
maybe 277,000 hours where you actually
choose. Every hour you spend is gone
forever. Unlike money, unlike mistakes,
you can't earn back time. Your phone,
it's a slot machine in your pocket.
Those notification dots are designed
like casino tricks to steal your hours.
But here's the plot twist. Once you see
the clock, you can't unsee it. Just
knowing this makes you see life
differently. If your parents are 60, you
have maybe 20 more holidays together.
That's not a lot. The full video reveals
how to reclaim your hours before they
vanish.